[Applaudissements]
sciences bonjour à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue pour ce stop science nous
allons vous reparler des tortues il y a
quelques unes de nos vidéos dont le
contenu est resté remarquablement au
goût du jour comme celle sur les
dinosaures des infos scientifique
toujours juste depuis janvier 2013 on
était vraiment des précurseurs à
l'époque oui mais voilà toutes nos
vidéos n'ont pas aussi bien vieilli et
il y en a une en particulier qui est
devenu obsolète
à peine un an après sa mise en ligne et
cette vidéo c'est celle sur les tortues
il est donc temps de remettre à jour
notre connaissance des tortues avec
toutes les magnifiques ces surprenantes
découvertes qui ont été faites ces cinq
dernières années déjà commençons par
identifier l'objet de nos préoccupations
les tortues c'est super d'être vivant sa
carapace se certain que n'importe qui
est capable d'identifier une tortue au
premier coup d'oeil la carapace et à la
tortue c'est que les incisives sont aux
rongeurs ou de pouce opposable aux
primates à de rares exceptions près
comme les tortues molle trio liquider
les tortues ont une carapace dure bien
pratique pour les paléontologues car
elle se fossilise très facilement pour
quelques fragments d'os manifeste de
dinosaures découverts les paléontologues
découvre souvent des dizaines de
morceaux de carapaces de tortues elles
sont pour cela très utile lors de la
recherche de fossiles car comme elles
vivent souvent dans l'eau là où les
fossiles se forment le mieux elle
indique où les probabilités de trouver
des fossiles de mammifères ou de
dinosaures seront les plus grandes
découvrir un bout de carapaces de tortue
c'est toujours bon signe
parlons-en justement de leur carapace la
carapace des tortues n'est pas une sorte
de coki dont les tortues peuvent se
débarrasser n'importe quand non non non
non en fait elle fait partie intégrante
de leur squelette un squelette visible
de l'extérieur vous devez avoir du mal à
croire ça pourtant les tortues un bel et
bien réaliser le vieux fantasme
d'inventer un exosquelette la carapace
de tortue c'est quoi juste le résultat
de la fusion de leur cage thoracique
avec des écailles épaisse est aussi fier
qu'on appelle ostéo dern austérité armes
qu'elle possède aussi les crocodiles
ainsi en regardant à l'intérieur de la
carapace d'une tortue vous découvrirez
que les côtes et les vertèbres de la
colonne vertébrale sont toutes fusionner
les unes aux autres et que le tout et
fusionner à l'extérieur avec des
écailles aussi fier le ventre qu'on
appelle plastron et composé quant à lui
des cas identifiés à l'extérieur et de
côtes ventrale qu'on appelle des gars
strahl y ait les épaules vous avez vu où
elles sont les épaules elles ne sont pas
l'extérieur de la cage
racisme et à l'intérieur imaginez si
vous aviez vos épaules à l'intérieur de
votre thorax c'est pas dingue ça en même
temps c'est un peu ça qui leur permet de
rentrer la tête et les bras pour se
protéger dans leur carapace alors
heureusement que leurs épaules sont pas
l'extérieur
bref pour vous la faire courte la
carapace des tortues ce sont des eaux de
la cage thoracique et de l'abdomen tous
fusionner autour des épaules
et si on y réfléchit bien cela veut dire
que quelque part dans le passé pas loin
de 300 millions d'années en arrière il a
dû exister un ancêtre des tortues sans
carapace avec une cage thoracique et des
épaules normale et au bon endroit
vous pouvez imaginer ce à une seconde ça
serait un peu comme d'imaginer un
éléphant ça trompe abba puisqu'on en
parle quand on remonte suffisamment loin
dans le passé on en trouve des éléphants
qui ne portait pas de trompes ni de
défense et qu'ils n'étaient pas plus
gros qu'un cochon et il ne vivait qu'il
n'ya 50 millions d'années on vous invite
à voir la vidéo de simplex paléo pour en
savoir plus
maintenant imaginez quelle distance
évolutive ont parcouru les tortues
depuis leur origine
il n'y a pas 50 il n'y a pas cent il n'y
a pas deux sens mais il ya 300 millions
d'années
c'était plus de 50 millions d'années
avant les tout premiers dinosaures
regardez cette tortue la ligne j'ai mis
ce dont le nom signifie tortues ninja
non non on ne plaisante pas
regardez à quel point c'était aux
pointes acérées sa carapace massy les
sacs plein de piquant à la rente
différente de toutes les tortues vous
connaissez eh bien ils gémissent n'a
même pas 2 millions d'années à temps là
c'est quoi que je lis en bas ces noms
d'espèces dungey miss oh oui ni owen i
qui veut dire comme owen dans jurassic
warba puis tu dis moi que c'est comme
owen dans jurassic ouverte que c'est ce
6e où elle l'a dont tu parles lundi non
non non je crains que cette espèce qui a
été nommé en l'honneur du véritable du
seul et unique de la terreur des
petits-enfants
seul richard owen
[Musique]
mais enlever cette enfance ses genoux
est pareil si tu prononces trois fois
son nom rapidement en tenant une
statuette enroulé dans du jambon il
apparaît dans ton dos déjà essayer non
j'ose pas mais en jetant bon il va
devoir
et puis voici odonto kelis 220 millions
d'années au compteur et qui a la
particularité de ne pas posséder de
carapace sur le dessus bien que n'étant
pas directement apparenté au trio nikki
des modernes aux dons o'kelly c'était
peut-être la toute première tortue à
carapace molle qui soit apparue la perte
de la carapace dure est d'ailleurs assez
courante chez les tortues marines
moderne
en témoigne la célèbre tortue luth et sa
carapace en cuir souple alors ceux qui
disent que les tortues sont des fossiles
vivants qui n'ont pas évolué peuvent
aller se rhabiller et nous expliquer au
passage pourquoi il s'était déshabillé
d'ailleurs non parce que là on a déjà
deux tortues fort différentes des
tortues moderne et on n'a même pas
encore fait ne serait-ce qu effleurer
les racines de l'arbre évolutif les
appeler fossile vivant c'est négliger
des centaines de millions d'années
d'évolution qui ont donné naissance à
plus de 300 espèces vivantes
rien que ça c'est autant que d'espèces
de primates on peut faire un parallèle
avec l'évolution des armes de g il ya
d'abord eu les javelots de simples
bâtons pointus qu'on lance puis on a
inventé des objets pour lancer des
bâtons pointus
d'abord le propulseur puis l'arc et les
flèches s'en venait ensuite l'arbalète
diablement puissante puis les armes à
feu si aujourd'hui tout le monde
s'accorde pour dire que nous vivons dans
l'ère des armes à feu diriez-vous
pourtant que les arcs modernes sont des
reliques du passé
je ne crois pas non et bien les tortues
c'est pareil oui parce qu'on les connaît
les idées reçues les tortues c'est
souvent gros voire très gros ça le sang
froid on en trouve plein de fois ci et
ça fait fortement penser à des reliques
du passé alors pouf on en fait des vrais
si vivant pour pas dire carrément qu'on
en fait les dinosaures
c'est même une idée qu'on retrouve
couramment y compris dans la presse il
est donc temps de clarifier tout ça les
tortues ont un crâne simple sans
ouverture à part pour les yeux et les
narines
ce type de craine est appelée à nab side
et est considérée comme primitif comparé
au crâne des mammifères qui porte une
ouverture supplémentaire la fosse
synapses id est aussi comparé au crâne
des lézards des crocodiles et des
dinosaures qui porte au moins deux
ouvertures supplémentaires et qu'on
appelle dioxyde la réputation de
fossiles vivants des tortues n'est pas
tout à fait étrangère à la simplicité de
leur crâne qu'elle partage avec de très
anciens et il les paras reptiles comme
le pareille aux russes et le scud aux
eaux riches en effet à une certaine
époque on ne croyait pas possible de
voir un crâne se doter de faux
supplémentaires puis de les reperdre
plus tard au fil de l'évolution
oui mais ça c'était avant
avant que les analyses adn s'en mêle les
analyses génétiques des tortues ont en
effet montré qu'elle n'était pas issu
d'un très ancien groupe de par un
reptile
oh que non alors qu'on s'attendait à les
voir comme des parents éloignés des
autres reptiles une relique de
l'évolution en fait elle se branche très
haut dans l'arbre du vivant
quelque part entre les lézards et les
crocodiles or si vous avez bien suivi
les crocos et les lézards honte akron
dit apside à deux ouvertures derrière
lors bits
cela veut dire que l'ancêtre commun des
lézards des tortues et des crocos avait
thakran dit abside et que par extension
les tortues ont vu ces ouvertures se
refermer ce n'est pas totalement
impossible
c'est notamment ce qui s'est passé avec
les oiseaux et le monstre de gila un
lézard
oui mais qui n'est plus directs ciid
cela à deux applications majeures
la première c'est que cette image de
l'évolution des tortues à partir d'un
parent reptile est fausse et de deux
cela implique que les tortues aurait
tellement évolué que leur anatomie ne
rendrait plus compte de leur lien de
parenté avec les crocodiles et les
lézards
donc si on regarde assez loin dans le
registre fossile on devrait trouver des
tortues très ancienne qui devait
posséder des ouvertures dioxyde dans le
crâne c'est à peu près là que ça a été
notre ancienne vidéo sur les tortues sur
la prédiction qu'un jour on trouverait
peut-être un ancêtre des tortues dioxyde
belle prédictions oui puisqu'elle s'est
avéré vérifier c'est beau la science
seulement quand elle est bien faite
attention des filles sont en train de
gonfler il nous faut remonter au permien
il ya 250 millions d'années
à cette époque vivait dans ce qui
deviendra bien plus tard l'afrique du
sud
un petit animal nommé millet l'état ce
n'est pas le plus ancien parent des
tortues mais c'est certainement ce qui
illustre le mieux à quoi ressemblait
l'ancêtre des tortues un petit reptile
au look de lézards avec des côtes
normale et ses épaules en dehors du
thorax non la plus ancienne tortue connu
c'est hunt aux russes qui vivait il y à
260 millions d'années lui aussi en
afrique du sud
une auto russe a la particularité
d'avoir à thorax très court de forme
hémisphérique évoquant presque une
carapace et ses côtes sont très larges
et presque fusionner les unes aux autres
comme chez les tortues actuelle les
cotes sont tellement étalé sur le côté
que la cassure est en forme de t comme
chez les tortues actuelle une auto russe
est donc bel et bien à proches parents
des tortues et son crâne et à 9,6 au
crâne et à 9,6 pda d'abc son crâne n'a
pas dit un psy qui c'est qu'a écrit ce
script crespin ça et pas d'ouverture
supplémentaire dans le crâne de notes
aux russes il est passé où l'autre la
eos est quoi ce travail de sion non mais
attends mais mais tourner la page là et
son crâne est en abside al
l'adulte mais il est dit à petit chez
les juvéniles à avait eu ça veut dire
que les jeunes monos taurus naissait
avec deux ouvertures supplémentaires
dans le crâne qui se ferme et ensuite
pendant leur croissance
c'est un peu long au génie qui
récapitule la phylogénie en quelque
sorte une note aux russes montrent que
les ancêtres des tortues étaient bien
dit abside allô oui oui ok et ben allez
vous faire voir cette équipe
l'association des pinailleurs d'internet
qui voulais te dire qu'être dit apside à
l'état juvénile pour eux c'est pas une
preuve a alors dans ce cas je vous
présente pas populiste du triest notre
voisine l'allemagne comme une auto
russie la décôte en forme de t ce qui le
rattache tortue moderne sauf que lui il
possède un crâne dioxyde même à l'âge
adulte
talât allô oui oui
ah ok oui eh ben vous pouvez vous les
mettre où je pense encore les
pinailleurs oui ils comprennent pas que
papou qu'ils y soient plus primitif que
nos taurus alors qu'il est apparu 30
millions d'années après c'est vrai que
c'est un peu compliqué
papaux kelly c'était à eux note aux
russes que l'ornithorynque est aux
mammifères d'aujourd'hui c'est un peu un
fossile vira banon ça fait une heure
combat s'il les gens pour qu'ils
arrêtent de dire fossiles vivants alors
maintenant tu utilises les bons mots
s'il te plaît bon d'accord
papaux kelly c'était un représentant
d'une très ancienne lignée de tortues
qui a survécu jusqu'au trias satisfaites
j'aime mieux s'arrimer l'âge ne compte
pas c'est de la position dans l'arbre
évolutif compte mais du coup ces
fameuses côtes à la section en forme de
t qui unissent ces anciennes espèces aux
tortues moderne elle servait à quoi et
bien d analyse minutieuse de la texture
des eaux ont montré qu'elle était
attachée à des muscles situés à
l'intérieur de la carapace et qui
servent tortue moderne à respirer ah oui
si vous regardez un lézard respirer il
utilise le mouvement de ses côtes pour
compresser et dilatés sa cage thoracique
et donc ses poumons mais les tortues
elles elles peuvent pas faire ça et oui
les proies des certains vous le diront
dans un ultime souffle respirer sans
faire bouger ses côtes c'est pas évident
la tortue de la fitzroy river en
australie a trouvé une solution
originale elle aspire de l'eau par le
cloaque et l'oxygène se diffuse par des
villosités perméable qui diffuse
d'oxygène à travers des capillaires très
fin et en français ça donne quoi
respire par le cul tu es contente oui
c'est très drôle mais cela ne reste
qu'un moyen secondaire d'acquérir de
l'oxygène et n'est néanmoins pas ce que
font la très vaste majorité des tortues
comme la cage thoracique des tortues fx
elle possède un muscle spéciale qui sert
de piston dans le thorax et qui
compresse les poumons en faisant la
preuve de l'existence de ce muscle chez
eux note aux oreilles c'est papon kelis
ces analyses dont nous parlions des
montres indirectement que la cage
thoracique de notes aux russes et de
papoter is ne pouvait déjà plus bouger
comme chez les tortues moderne
tu crois qu'ils avaient une carapace en
cartilage a peut-être bien qu'oui
peut-être bien que non qui se trouve
l'évolution d'une respiration par piston
était une condition nécessaire à
l'évolution de la carapace plus tard
c'est ce qu'on appellerait une pré
adaptation ou prêt habitation malgré
tout pas poker c'est une auto russe
posséder quelques différences
remarquables avec la plupart et tortueux
déjà il s'agissait d'animaux terrestres
et pas à quoi tic ou semi aquatique une
histoire évolutive des tortues a
commencé sur terre peut être même sous
terre si on en croit les énormes pas de
notorious qui suggère fortement qu'il
était capable de creuser des terriers de
plus papou kelly c'est une auto russe
n'avait ni carapace ni bec et posséder
encore des dents mais tout cela va
changer au trias il y à 210 millions
d'années
fini les ébauches de tortue maintenant
c'est du lourd c'est du massif des
vertèbres et des côtes totalement
fusionner entre elles
auxquels s'ajoutent des écailles aussi
fier et des épines sur la tête le cou et
la queue une tête massive et sans
ouverture supplémentaire une qu en masse
d'armé aux pointes acérées retrouver
partout dans le monde dans des gisements
suggérant un mode de vie partiellement
aquatique
elle représente le premier grand succès
des êtres à carapace il s'agit de
non non pas buzzer non mais non non il
s'agit en fait de prog anouk ellis plus
de 150 millions d'années avant les
ankylose or elle a littéralement inventé
la stratégie de la forteresse vivante
mais attention sa carapace est une vraie
carapace de tortue fait principalement
de ce couvert des cas il ne suffit pas
simplement de rester aux dames comme
chez reed en philosophe prog anouk et
lisse comme l'étendue d'eau aujourd'hui
posséder une carapace complète ses
épaules se trouvant à l'intérieur
aulas elles sont prêtes à les porter
quand même non elles ont tout simplement
fait le tour par devant c'est en tout
cas ce que suggère l'anatomie des
tortues du trias de chine et auraient qu
calicéo d'auto kelis regardez là on voit
bien que les omoplates sont situés à
l'avant de son corps et pas sur le
dessus et oreo kelis c'est un peu le
nôtre horus 2.0 car en plus d'avoir des
épaules à l'avant du corps elle a aussi
une bouche qui portait à la fois un bec
et des dents à mi chemin entre nos
taurus et pro gano kelis même si ses
épaules se trouvait déjà dans sa
carapace n'est pas pour autant que
progrès de kelis avait une tête
rétractable la tête rétractable dans la
carapace est néanmoins présente chez
certaines tortues contemporaine de prog
anouk ellis et personne n'est vraiment
sûr du nombre de fois que cette
caractéristique est apparu et a disparu
chez les tortues
on sait qu'il est apparu au moins deux
fois puisque les tortues modernes ont
deux façons différentes de rétracter
leur tête soit par le côté verticalement
ou alors horizontalement
cela donne un résultat similaire mais
les conséquences sur le squelette et les
muscles sont très différentes
on sait aussi que les capacités a
rétracté la tête est généralement perdu
chez les tortues marines
ça a l'air de rien dit comme ça mais là
on parle d'aller retour évolutif
constant d'une condition à une autre au
fil des 200 millions d'années ou plus
qui sépare ces tortues de celle qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui
en conclusion vous l'aurez compris les
tortues sont bien puisant signe que les
dinosaures et ont parcouru un chemin
évolutif qu'il est injuste de résumer
par l'expression aubin une tortue c'est
juste une tortue elles sont apparues et
se sont diversifiées bien avant les
mammifères et les dinosaures évoluant
sans cesse depuis rencontrant à toutes
les époques un grand succès évolutif
survivants à toutes les crises et
s'adaptant aussi bien au milieu
terrestre que marin ou d'eau douce
maintenant vous n'avez plus d'excusés
les tortues ne sont ni des dinosaures ni
des fossiles vivants qu'on ne vous y
reprenne plus merci à tous
[Musique]